et on est avec has more heroes à ce qui
est avec nous et gasquet qui est très
bon qu'est dans la grosse rigolade
d'ailleurs on est en train de voir si on
va se faire une grosse rigolade ici très
bientôt en direct avec tous les poteaux
pour mollement moise times blague c'est
qui a c'est qui ça concerne qui cette
blague qu'il va mourir et pour amour et
il a besoin d'un ton de sang ouais sur 7
200 cas le même sens que lui sa guise
donc il va voir l'imam il lui dit
franchement je vais mourir j'ai besoin
d'entendre sans mais le seul mec a le
même sens que moi c'est un juif il a tué
le suicide s'empêcher chez nous ou pas
se suicider tu demandes depuis soit
passé son sang il va demander aux juifs
les juifs il va voir un rabbin eelv
avant le rappel il ya un arabe qui me
demande qui monte et monte dans tant de
sang et où commencer par valérie duby
des fans d'action
tu lui donnes ton sang le juif est de
900 à l'arabe l'arabie commence à aller
mieux pour le remercier et lui donne une
ferrari une maison ça pas 5 ans 10 ans
l'arabie rechute hilare besoin de sang
il va voir le juif le juif il donne du
sens la rapport le remercier de l'offre
une twingo
le juge va réfléchir comme ça il y
pensait pas grasse 5 ans 10 ans l'arabie
rechute encore il va voir les filets
redemande surfant le juif et lui donne
son sang el arabi lui donne une
bicyclette pour le remercier
le bus 8 ans soit possible il va voir
leur appétit je comprends pas été malade
la première fois ma de lille c'est rare
et une maison la deuxième fois m'a donné
une twingo et la troisième fois il donne
une bicyclette
le rappel tiao est mais oublie pas qu
ils attention maintenant t'es con ça
rigole merci menace d'amour et aux
thèmes forts est une invite de voir
quand on peut et on t'aime mon frérot on
t'aime tu es une bombe on a que le
spectacle reprenne à son spectacle à y
voir des concerts va reprendre
il est exceptionnel je t'embrasse très
fort mon frérot on t'aime et tu es beau
gosse bravo bravo bravo pour le physique
à regarder qui m'appelle adil rami tiens
mon ami mon pote adil rami qui m'appelle
comment ça va mon adil c'est adil rami
mon frérot ça va mon habileté qui vous
toise et en russie sur direct je suis à
la maison là
en tentant là tu m'appelles savamment
théorie toi ça va
ouais bah t'as raison mon frérot tu vas
chez les lourds virtuellement et adil
c'est une bande de mecs lui voilà c'est
le genre de mec dont on a besoin en ce
moment
ce qui fait que voilà inouïe nous mais
il nous met de la dark eye nommé du kif
mon frérot est et si je viens en russie
un jour je passe te vois avec plaisir
vos frères je t'aime fort tout va bien
toi en russie vous n'êtes pas confiné or
ici parce que les gens quand tu es dans
la vue la plainte qui pas nui tu trouves
que c'est court et encore du pq et le
truc le dieu de faire la main ouais
c'est ça tu vas encore des photos tout
ça quand tu consultes maintenant
comprennent pas que tu vas te revois
bien sûr ah ouais c'est ça ben oui c'est
normal beaumont a dit en tout cas tu
nous donnes des news mon chéri fait
attention quand même et on t'aime fort
je t'embrasse on a dit mme frereault
t'inquiète je t'ai pas vu je t'ai jamais
vu je t'embrasse fort on t'aime voilà
c'est adil rami